[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday April
11th and I hope you don't mind if I do
something a little bit different today
last week you showed us a day in the
life of John Green writing as writers do
this week I would like to show you a
little bit about what I do but not so
much by videotaping myself staring at my
computer and typing as we discovered by
watching your video that wasn't very
interesting but instead by discussing
some of the biggest issues happening in
green technology at the moment residents
of the virtual world Second Life were
surprised by floodwaters rising in
virtual versions of Tokyo London and the
Netherlands the floods were caused by
global warming activists but not in the
cool hacking the system kind of way in
the really lame asking everybody
permission and then doing it kind of way
you might not know this but there is
more silicon purchased by the solar
power industry than by the
microprocessor industry it's right
silicon isn't very easy to make in fact
it's really dangerous and produces a lot
of toxic chemicals unless you're a
marine sponge marine sponges are one of
the only organisms in the world that can
convert aqueous silicon to crystalline
silicon and the sponges do without
producing any toxic chemicals at all
scientists at the University of
California at Santa Barbara trying to
figure out how those sponges are doing
it and they've had some success when we
talk about lighting there are a few
things that matter one how bright the
light is
two how big the light is three how much
energy the light uses in for how many
toxic substances go into creating the
light compact fluorescents we're doing
pretty good there until number four with
all their mercury but now philips
electronics has produced the lux Eon
rebel an LED that is tiny produces tons
of light the little electricity and
absolutely no toxic substances this is
great news until you consider the fifth
thing that matters when it comes to
lighting and that's price and this is
not very cheap I've got a lot of these
and I'm not proud of it that's a lot of
plastic for a very little gain but some
cover guy in some clever place has
posted a picture to Flickr of his
ingenious use of CD spindles a
motorcycle created and maintained by a
1-2-3 systems has broken the electric
motorcycle speed record once again
the motorcycle is powered by a lot of
lithium-ion batteries and broke the
speed record using ten cents of
electricity that's pretty good the bike
peaked out at 156 miles per hour and
finished the quarter mile in 9 seconds
the City of Sydney turned off its lights
all of them for an hour last week s it
saved mounts of carbon that sound very
big lots of tons of carbon but mostly it
was just a great opportunity to take a
pretty picture and say that Australia is
doing something even though they won't
sign on to the Kyoto Protocol not that
us Americans can talk and that's the
news from eco geek org if you want to
find out more details on those stories
or read up on more green technology news
check out eco Guiteau org so what did
you think John was that was that like is
that good
you like that thinking about doing a
podcast for you go geeking out and try
it out the opinions appreciated cool
I'll see you tomorrow